ouais tout s'il est malade il faut
toujours que tu en fasses des tonnes
quand arrive c'est dans ma nature d'en
faire des tonnes j'y peux rien on se
connaît depuis qu'on vienne te bats
comme nos mères respectives ont grandi
ensemble je dirais qu'on s'est connus
avant même notre naissance
il n'y a pas de raison pour pré change
du perso jusqu'à la tombe bien raison et
la soirée fait que commencer
vous êtes folle dupes les deux ouais ça
te plaît ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai tu
sais plus avec ces deux-là plus amant
d'avoir quelqu'un de spécial dans la vie
et beauté toi tu es alors toi tu
t'arrêtes tout de suite de me toucher tu
leur fais plus jamais ça vas-y laisse
tomber a raison mais je partir de toute
façon pas et on va y aller nous aussi on
accourt demain matin rod si tu veux moi
je restais un peu avec ma copine nadine
est inquiète en ce bas demain soit
partagé vous bien
comme avant il est bientôt mec devrait
peut-être aussi aller dans ton
université de bourges pour me trouver en
bobine j'ai pas arrêter de te le dire
ouais mais j'ai un boulot ou au mois
tout ce que je veux dire c'est à
d'autres talents à part celui
d'enseigner tu peux pas acheter tout ça
quand ça risque pas parquet tu voi type
là bas au bar il va m'offrir des verts
pendant toute la soirée
il veut boire quelques sud se boit pas
d'alcool
tu sais médias on a offert un beau
spectacle musique hip hop au moins nous
payer des coups à boire